if i don't meet them
and we don't have that
connection where they're like you're my
son you're my dad i'll jerk off to him
[Music]
my name is danielle priory and i'm here
to answer the internet would you rather
be magic johnson with aids or a regular
dude with no aids this is a good
question so here's the reason why he's a
billionaire also he's had hiv for 700
years so if you really think about it
magic johnson will probably die from
something other than aids
and also that video came out recently of
him just being like sometimes i had sex
with eight sometimes i had sex with nine
he lived a pretty dope life so i'm gonna
actually i'll take the eights dallas
buyers club came out and like kind of
like made aids like gross again yeah but
like ages aids is like kind of you it's
very very
treatable would you rather have aids or
herpes eights all the way but herpes is
gross aids is kind of retro and cool so
you know what i mean that's throwback
which nfl team would win all white
players are all black players i mean
well bill belichick has discovered that
it's all white players i'm going to go
with all black players because
let's just be honest i need some guys
who are going to go out there and be
faster than the white guys best wide
receiver ever is black that question's
like 10
years question made more sense when it
was asked because we got the more
jacksonville
that's what i'm saying
presenting
the black guy
pat mahomes is black his brother's wife
his brother's wife pat's black jack's
wife that's what that is but yeah give
me the all black players all the time
plus they're more fun would you [ __ ]
kelly that's easy question uh would you
[ __ ] kelly ripa yes but if you had to be
in a threesome with regis philbin regis
rest in peace i thought regis philbin
died a couple of times yeah um yeah
because nobody could say that they
[ __ ] both kelly ripa and regis philbin
i think that question it makes me want
to [ __ ] him more yeah dude and you know
he would say some cool stuff and he's
got a great voice i let reed just take
me to pound town
it's probably uncircumcised
uh would you rather have two normal kids
or one disabled kid and one kid in the
nfl yes because they would get like a
really cool like espn short where like
you know like where my son's really cool
and he takes care of his younger brother
you know what i mean and then it cuts to
me i'm just like
it's just been such a blessing in my
life
and one tear comes down
and then they like show us like slow
motion like walking through the tunnel
with like him on his shoulders and stuff
you know what i mean that's that's what
i want that's what i want a disney movie
out of that yeah
that same studio that's making the
current one-on-one yeah and then and
then if you get to the super bowl then
it becomes the two weeks where like you
have like the press
and then it becomes a huge story line
that people start rooting for them you
know what i mean i want the story i want
the stories yeah give me the disabled
kid and give me the nfl kid because one
of them's got money i could just have
two kids that are losers too
would you let hitler sleep at your house
everyone had an uncle a laugh like that
would you rather get projectile vomited
on by a homeless person for an hour
straight or get your dick sucked by a
toothless homeless person with no gag
reflex okay so i've done both so this
could be a this could be a sex of my
choice dude i'm getting a blow job bro
it's just like you know there's doing
this in new york right now
and they paid for it there's a fetish
there's a homeless fetish have you guys
ever heard about that no there's a
homeless fetish where guys that only
want to have sex with homeless women
yeah look it up when you're done with
this look it up and you're not going to
think i'm so great or they want you to
be [ __ ] homeless they wanna they
literally go around where they know
we're like where prostitutes are look it
up dude
and the uh yeah they fetishize the
homeless would you rather have flamingo
legs or t-rex arms i think flamenco
flamingos are majestic because like
when you see a full flamingo you're like
that's majestic but if you saw it on a
person you'd be like this dude has like
ms and like this kid's had polio he was
one of those kids that didn't get
vaccinated when he was a kid you know
what i'm saying so like i mean but t-rex
arms are a little bit more cool because
now i have a halloween costume all the
time picked out give me the t-rex arms i
don't want to be one of those guys
skipped leg day guys i don't want to do
that
would you kill a baby hitler's actually
in this question
okay now we're getting somewhere now
we're now removing the needle uh
would you kill baby hitler if it had to
be in a very gruesome way
yeah dude i have way too many friends
that are jews you know what i mean so
like i would be a hero
that's what i'm saying my
oh yeah that's true
now how gruesome are we talking about am
i taking am i taking hitler's head off
yeah i mean there's an axe in the
picture so
yeah i'm killing the [ __ ] out of this
baby because listen man if you just do
the numbers one baby
gruesomely murdered
millions of jews let's kill that baby
listen i love new york city i love
everything about you guys cats deli is
one of my favorite places in the world
so yeah let's kill baby hitler and let's
do it together i'll do it on twitch
would you date your dream girl if for
two days every week your choice she had
to dress like a juggalo she'd be my
jugaho there's nothing wrong with
juggalo culture see like i see a lot of
people like make fun of juggalos and
[ __ ] but if you've ever seen like uh
like vice they always send like uh yeah
you know like a really like skinny like
lesbian girl out they send her to like
all these things and she went to the
juggalo thing and they were all so nice
they're weird people but we're weird
people too we're just more acceptable
weird it's like um how like jocks or
jocks but like dude you're a [ __ ]
nerd you know [ __ ] bobby bonilla's
career lifetime average you're a [ __ ]
nerd
that's the reason religion's more [ __ ]
up than juggalos is because religion
leads to people getting murdered
juggalos just turns into a good time
dress that [ __ ] up would you rather be
in a modern world
i'm just imagining today with only
pregnant chicks and cats and you can't
watch porn
or live in a world where everyone is
your mother and father and you can watch
porn i've made a lifetime of my mother
and father and jerking off around them i
would figure it out
i'm not saying that i need porn but i
need it dude first of all you're not
even taking you're not even taking into
account you get mad christmas presents
you mad birthday presents you got so
many dads and moms and [ __ ]
billions of presents bro from all over
the world and you get the jerk off dude
is the porn haul your mom and dad
because it's this whoa
oh [ __ ] i didn't think about that yeah i
think it would kind of be like an i am
legends situation if i don't meet them
and we don't have that
connection where they're like you're my
son you're my dad i'll jerk off to him
if you can live anyone's life in their
body who would you be i'd be probably
like a jason mamoa tall absolute smoke
you could probably bang whatever you
want in the world you know what i mean
zoe kravitz is like your stepdaughter or
some [ __ ] you know i mean he's got a
very nice
skin tone yeah yeah he's got a
miscellaneous face he could do
everything if he didn't have like the
big ass tattoo you wouldn't really know
he could be filipino he could be uh
spanish white black spanish give me
mamoa all day and you know he's got
everybody and you know he's got a piece
he doesn't have a penis
he's got a [ __ ] that dude's dick is
outrageous um if you could put any
franchise restaurant in your house what
would it be that is a great question i'm
gonna stay true to my fat roots here i
went through a big burger king phase
yeah i was pretty poor but if i had to
pick a full thing that isn't fast food
i'm going to go with pf janks i could
still feel classy eating shitty food
because when you go into a pf change
you're like oh this place looks really
really nice and then they give you like
4 000 grams of sodium and like one piece
of general shell's chicken so i want the
decor pf chang's a little nicer than a
[ __ ] burger king where people like
tie off and die in the bathroom yeah i
don't want anything that's going to be
open at midnight because then you're
going to have people just trying to come
to your house all the time give me pf
changs give me the decor give me the
franchise i'm going with pf changs all
the way also their kung pao chickens
outrageous yeah yeah yeah a little
overpriced though
would you rather be able to have sex
with any five people for a year
or get the powerbomb whoever you want
whenever you want for a year i'm a big
wrestling fan but sex is awesome and any
five people for a year you're taking the
sex bro i'm taking the sex bro before
you were gonna take the power no no no
no no no because here's the thing about
the power bomb i can get desensitized to
a power bomb
but if if you have five different women
who has the ability to crush their top
five realistically honestly for what i
do for a living i could probably get
someone to let me powerbomb them legally
dude you can go to a [ __ ] bills game
and powerbomb somebody you know what i
mean can i [ __ ] rihanna no you know
what's a really cool story telling
somebody you powerbomb somebody you know
it's even cooler story telling you you
power drilled
who's famous rihanna's number one i saw
her in person once and we connected eyes
and it felt like the world stopped
spinning she's outrageous to look at in
person she's tall salma hayek but from
dusk till dawn salma hayek billy
madison's girlfriend
pete sampras's wife uh veronica vaughn
that's how you know i'm old i know
he's [ __ ] sampras i'll go into the
porn realm uh jenna jameson uh no no no
take that out heather i deep throat you
guys remember heather at [ __ ] what
was that movie uh where diane lane
uh
unfaithful it's a tie between her and
julia louis-dreyfus
eclectic
yeah you know everyone's like give me
these titties and ass i'm like i want
some nostalgia and some like that that's
[ __ ] elaine
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon